哈囉我是小三零
今天我想分享一個可以整就我們明明機與水火之中的
下停反輸你之心
就在前幾天我又用A成翻車了
用的時候沒有什麼感覺
但過了幾天之後那兩
好痛靠痛虎拉拉的
就像把拉拉腳塗在臉上的一樣
我就每天晚上都做這個輸明之心
好的飛快
而且不只是急就翻車
日常明明換進明明或者是
抱歉之後都可以用這一套流程
每天都可以做
那在分享加天反輸明之心之前
我想先分享一下
明明機怎麼震圈的洗臉
因為我發現很多明明機的姐妹
都不會震圈洗臉
但其實把臉洗好
我們的平常就好了一般人了
連洗不好的話
或許就算用修護力
快好的護品
你感覺效果也是有限的
我剛剛用紅石器有很煩的事
你就是本來感覺臉不怎麼紅了
但是一洗完整個臉
就變得通紅
就是因為我錯誤的洗臉手法在洗臉的時候
就相當於是在煞愛皮膚
就很多點了一上來
就開始在這打圈
流脫把自己的臉當盤子一樣再脫
這場這樣脫是沒有問題的
但如果是在明明時期
還這樣脫的話
就容易把平常洗飽了
比如說我們臉上
這塊是需要修護的地方
它很明
然後你現在的手
你一直在這
脫脫的
那你要它怎麼修護
它表面上好
會用修護的這一層
你怎麼一脫
又把它給脫沒了
而且脫起來很痛
正確的手範
應該是先把洗臉臉的泡沫
那在手上
然後我們的手
像西盤一樣
按壓我們的臉
雖然比我們打圈的話
會多花一點時間
但是這樣呢
洗得又很乾淨
而且不會上平常
把臉上的泡沫洗完了之後
用毛巾
不要擦
把臉上水分這樣按掉
接下來就是舒美之心的環節了
其實我在1月份的時候
就開始在研究
這個家庭版的舒美之心
但是一直都沒有跟大家分享的原因
就是我始終覺得
那個效果都不夠停燕
但是今天分享這套
我是覺得不管是從效果
還是從體驗感上來說都非常好
舒美之心的原理
其實就是幫我們深度不水
去模糊
減少紅命的問題
所以需要用的是多尾度
供效很全的修護精華
這就是我用的
必須能支援的後臉皮頓乾淨化
它在我們這個家庭版
收明之心裡面
非常非常重要
它是這種一支一支的
因為我之前也試過
用一些其他的修護刺炮
在這部流程裡面
但我發現
那麼都太年了
我後期呢會配合這個冷物理
後面會有點推不開的感覺
但是必須支援的這個腦
這裡很清爽
就像精華水一樣
所以哪怕我用到這麼一整支在臉上
皮會不會覺得年齡
這個精華離開的點
在於它把外秘體
就像基礎用在了後部屏裡面
還發表了相關的論文
雖然少少的一支
但它是從五千多片新鮮的
有感染夜裏面提卻能說出來的
所以在家用它的手機
其實就跟我們在外面
每個永遠做像五十一樣的
它是這種雙藏的設計
上面是精華
也像是洞乾粉
把這個環呢
給它拿掉
在
一眼看
就融合在一起了
我一般就會贏了幾秒鐘
把它們擺開
一定要配合冷夫以來做
這一部很重要
在我們皮膚明明發紅發燙的時候
這種物理教育的方式
會讓皮膚快速冷靜下
在皮膚這種
很紅很薄的地方可以
多停留一下
這個精華的標誇它
小小的一組
靈真的有很多
就在臉上垮動就行
我一般也就有垮動個
大概3分鐘的養子
我已經花完了
但是現在臉上還是
滿滿的精華耶
不用洗膠了
用手按壓
加速皮膚吸收
兩三下
它就會吸收完了
而且吸收完之後整個臉是
很清爽的
最後就是用一個
強修後的面雙來都封層
這個原因是我的第二品了
它不管是修後
還是緊救
還是舒緩效果
都非常好
致地是這種
熱門不膩的
也很適合做有命品姐妹
秋冬天使用的面雙
它是會有恰大好吃的保持
但是又不會溫夫
又下來很安心
這一套下來感覺
真的能夠把命令
是其需要的水分和營養
給我們补金皮膚裡面
舒緩效果非常好
我上週連很紅派
痛的時候都是這麼做的
一下子臉上那種
感到緊繃
和次次的感覺
就舒緩了很多
在做的過程中
也很享受
隔天起來臉上
那個紅命也好啊
很多
那這個家庭板
書名之心
明明級的寶貝
你們趕快試試吧